let's just bring you some breaking news
now and an announcement is expected
shortly on a proposed european super
league
a breakaway league which would upheld
the structures of both domestic
and european football as revealed by sky
news
last year our city editor mark climan
who broke the story joins me now on the
phone so mark what more can you tell us
well there's some very big developments
expected in the next few hours
about the proposed european super league
which will be a
a new format launched in competition
to uefa's champions league format
now uefa is planning to announce uh some
proposed
changes to the champions league uh
tomorrow
but this breakaway rival league is
expected to be announced tonight it will
include
england's top six clubs including
manchester united liverpool
arsenal and chelsea and my understanding
is that
12 clubs from across europe including
the six biggest english clubs have now
signed up to this new format the others
include barcelona
juventus and real madrid and this will
be an incendiary
move because of the timing uh coming
just hours before uefa
is supposed to announce details of the
revised uh
champions league format now uh some of
the details
are still sketchy and we will have to
wait until tonight
or potentially tomorrow uh to find out
fuller details about exactly what this
new league will involve but what i
reported last october
and still stands today is that the new
league
includes uh staggering sums of money
that will be handed to the participating
clubs about six billion dollars has been
committed to this new project by the
american bank jp morgan and this will
come
after of course european clubs finances
have been hard hit by the coronavirus
pandemic which is one of the reasons why
so many of europe's biggest clubs have
decided that now is the right
time to form a european super league
after years
of on off discussions about such a
project now i can also reveal this
afternoon
that the premier league has issued
already a
robust rebuttal of this european
breakaway
league plan uh in the last hour the
premier league's chief executive richard
masters has written to all 20
premier league clubs in england saying
this venture cannot be launched without
english clubs and we call upon any club
contemplating associating themselves
or joining this venture to walk away
immediately
before irreparable damage is done and mr
masters
goes on to say in this uh to clubs we do
not and cannot support such a concept
premier league rules contain a
commitment amongst clubs to remain
within the football pyramid
and forbid any club from entering
competitions uh beyond those
listed in the premier league's rules i
cannot envisage any scenario where
premier league board permission
would be granted so this really sets the
scene for
for a an explosive tussle between
uh the top power brokers in european
football
over these breakaway plans we've yet to
get confirmation from any of the
participating english clubs
about their involvement but remember
that over the last few months whenever
the likes of ed woodward who runs
manchester united have been asked about
these
european super league plans he's
attempted to dismiss
or distance manchester united from
any such plan it looks like there has
been
a lot of behind the scenes negotiation
in recent months
and we are now going to hear in the
coming hours about those plans coming to
fruition
a very very important day for european
football and for the future of english
football potentially